keep things simple we can start with a
couple warm-up games as we usually do
and then basically i wanted to play
maybe one or two odds games and then
through the lens of that to talk through
and review some basic principles
that we had been sort of building upon
and
then sort of the last thing i was
thinking we could do either some puzzles
or
i prepared a couple of positions that
may also allow us to review
some basic planning techniques stuff
like that and then we can finish with
like a game or two totally
uh you know we'll play it by you how
does that sound generally
all sounds good to me man i'm ready
[Music]
i can't believe you're actually playing
so you know the ropes
italian uh yup i immediately made a
mistake though
so nope this is good
this is good developments
and you basically know the drill in
these types of positions
this guy is just going to resign because
he knows you're making a comeback
he sees the name and he's already just
overrun with fear well he's already put
on a mask in the profile factory he
doesn't want you to like affect any part
of his
face okay so taking on f3 by the way
we already have stuff to effect that was
a mistake your queen is in a really good
attacking position
can you slide that queen over so it's in
an even better attacking position
yes sir pinning right there absolutely
get it
get it the hell over there
all right guys yeah i'm sorry i'm gonna
turn charlie yeah i can't believe you
want to hear him louder
okay so that's actually a good move yeah
and the question is where do you want to
tuck your queen away the queen can be
tucked away
and the blankets can be put over it but
it can still be really good so what
square am i talking about here
well it's not h2 right that's not really
a good square four it's not active yeah
oh you have a really sexy square
actually you see that bishop on c4
it's pinning the pawn on f7 which means
the pawn is paralyzed
which gives your queen a really sexy
square
uh i see just bringing it all the way up
to g6
yep exactly
bingo and that is a move that you used
to struggle with now look at the
you've really matured i have to say it's
like a completely different person i'm
speaking to
yeah i know i've hit the final level
ooh uh okay
so he wants to intercept your queen
uh and if you take that pawn with
anything but which piece
he'll take your queen so which piece do
you have to take the pawn with to
preserve the pit
i have to take it with the bishop
perfect
yeah you're gonna be making a smoothie
out of his out of this king's side
so he can actually take your bishop with
his queen that would be a pretty
advanced concept
which he does yeah a little [ __ ] but
actually you have something in store so
now you see that your queen is hanging
right
yeah can you save your queen and also
avoid losing a piece
well i can just drop the queen back to
g4 right well if you're already dropping
the queen back you might as well [ __ ]
take some [ __ ] while you're at it
what can the queen take just picking the
knight taking the knight because
remember he took your knight
so if you were to just drop the queen
back you'd be down a piece now you're up
a pawn
all right miss me yet
okay now it comes to mind
there is a particular plan and such
positions that i know you have a
particular fondness for
is it putting the knight on the outpost
at d5 well that's the plan i have a
funnel so go ahead and do that i'm
quite impressed actually
okay did i say the word impressed [ __ ] i
think you accidentally let that one slip
i accidentally put on deodorant this
morning so i was like what would a
russian trainer he would smell like
sweat i don't even know
it's weird how you put deodorant on now
even though you don't see anybody all
day
yeah i haven't put deodorant on in a
[ __ ] minute man dude it's [ __ ]
crazy
all these all these remnants of like
normal life anyways oh
he has blundered something
well there's a hanging pawn at c7 but i
imagine we want some
oh i mean that's a fourth queen that's a
fork on the queen in the rook that's a
whole [ __ ] package
yeah bingo good so you're still
pretty sharp in terms of the one move
tactic stuff like that
that's very good
yeah he's kind of [ __ ] here so think
about what you'll be doing after you
take his well
first perform the necessary duties
now remember that when you're up
something that involves a rook having
more rooks than your opponent
you want to open up files so the rooks
have to be
alive otherwise you're not going to feel
their power
so how can you do that i was looking at
pushing f4 pawn
yes that's correct perfect
and yeah there's stuff to talk about
here because you can take your pawn and
what are you going to take back with
i want to take with the bishop right
because then i'm attacking his queen
that's fine you can actually take with
either piece sticking with a rook a case
can be made for that
because you do want to open up files for
your ex but i like taking with your
bishop too
okay
all right he checks you no problem what
can you do
i just want to move the king back to h1
right yep exactly
and he's gonna take your pawn on b2 and
think he's the biggest [ __ ]
but that's actually helping you open up
file okay no he's not never mind
okay do you want to trade i'm up right
now right so i do want to make these
trades okay
absolutely he's probably going to take
the knight would be my assumption
and then that queen on d4 it's kind of
annoying can you get it out of there
yeah just pushing pawn at c3
and then by pushing pawn on c3 if you
notice your central pawns
uh and you know he can he take on d3
first of all
well let's see what he does no he
doesn't so now you can continue pushing
and getting his pieces out of these key
squares
yo i just want to push up the pawn again
to d4 together absolutely get the knight
out control the center
thanks nip nip for the bits
and now you need a simple plan you need
to decide what to do with your rooks
there is a simple thing you do with
rooks when you have an open file to put
them on
what do you do beckham stack them so
rook f3 rook yeah rook f3 is probably
the best place but the first one
uh because it's also sort of guarding
some key squares
so let's see yeah so he already curls up
into a ball
it doesn't change anything though
absolutely stack him thanks guys for the
subs
and then you'll have to use your pawns
together with your brooks
to just continue massaging his position
thanks guys for the subs
so i see even playing three-minute games
that's pretty good actually you've
definitely
sped up i can sense that yeah i mean
those three-minute games were a [ __ ]
disaster though i would not recommend
watching that unless you're trying to
throw up
well i usually am so he's attacking your
pawn on e4
how can you protect that while without
removing your pieces from their active
position
it's just pushing the pawn up right yep
yeah let's see what he does i mean look
at your pawn chain
that is that's what i look to
get my creative juices flowing okay so
obviously he's threatening the queen
trade which
which you want is your up material yeah
and now there's never a reason to
decline this when i'm up this much right
well not really we'll talk about that
after the game because you've got 49
seconds
yeah unless you want to talk about it
now so think about what you want to do
now you have a pawn on d4 that pawn has
passed
if you push that pawn you lose the pawn
on e5 he takes it with his knight
can you preemptively defend that other
pawn so you can push the d-pawn
yeah i'm just going up to f5 right yep
that's actually a perfect way to do it
because you're also attacking his pawn
all right so in fact you can go around
and take g5 first you don't even have to
rush by pushing your pawn
yeah let's see what he does
and you might lose on time the first
couple games that makes me happy to see
lose but
that's okay yeah we're working on the
yeah
and careful with your rook on g5 he
might drop his knife back to e6
uh and he might attack your rook so be
prepared to move it
no he doesn't so now we're going to push
him
pushing that key pawn and now you can
push either the e pawn or the d-pawn
it doesn't matter i would even push the
e pawn because if he takes that
you trade rooks which is again good for
you
totally depends on what he does
okay yeah and doesn't change anything
if he takes that pawn his last move g6
has allowed you to do something pretty
cool
so if he plays f takes e6
okay he plays f6 same move well can i
just take pawn and delivery
okay yep and then take the other pawn on
f6 and do that quickly
and now if he takes you take if he
doesn't okay
takes now you can push we'll push the e
pawn
and make so if he plays king to g7 you
can slide your rook over
before making a queen to preserve that
rook that'll make
it faster to deliver checkmate okay so
get your rockaway to f7 for example
f7 is better okay and then make a
[ __ ] queen right now
you can actually pre-move you can
pre-move yeah i see there's nothing he
can really do to defend that
yeah now you're just gonna ladder
checkmate depending on where he goes
with his knight
wow that that's pretty that's a lot of
faith in your ability to check man
to say well to be fair though it's only
it's two moves right i'm only going g8
and then i'm going h7 so yeah unless he
goes knight f6
uh so of course you saw that you were
just testing my
ability so let's let's quickly go over
that just a couple of points
um that that'll oil the machine then
you'll jump back into the pool
so i'll invite you to an analysis board
i'm sure you've missed that as well
all right so basically okay so does it
can you see my moves
yep so h6 is already a slightly
sketchy move we'll talk about that later
um right now i want to get the plans
down
get the basics down so this is a mistake
what should he have done instead
of taking the knight drop bishop back
yeah so
preserve the pin very important uh and
it makes a little bit hard for you to
basically move your pieces around so he
takes
this move makes sense right you're
threatening to take on h6
and potentially you're preparing to push
your pawn out to f4
this is like the sexiest move of the
game queen g6
um and that's also why playing h6 really
early can be a mistake and then castling
because obviously that weakens these
king side squares
so d5 you took and and here
uh you i mean in your mind you have to
be like okay he's taking a piece
so if i don't take a piece back i'm
gonna be a piece down which is why
if you're moving the queen you better
take the knight okay makes sense
so here now you go knight t5 outpost
take
everything open the files everything is
very logical
the one thing i want you to tell me what
would you have done if he had taken on
b2
wouldn't i just chase the queen away at
b1 bingo
so rook ab1 what if he takes another
pawn
well then i can go take his pawn on b7
exactly and you're threatening what move
then i'm coming at f7 nicely done and
last thing if he goes for cafe
can you chase that rook away from f8 and
get to f7
uh yeah i just bring bishop to d6 nice
and
extra credit question because you're
answering these quickly if queen takes
d3 what is the purpose of this move how
do you defend against it
he's attacking the bishop and he's
attacking the rook
um oh that's not what he's doing
ah
do you do i just take rook let him take
rook
get out of check and then go for f7 so
that's a that would not be a bad idea
if he takes your bishop here then okay
you're
you have the best idea ever the problem
is he won't take your bishop
you notice that your king is now kind of
weak so he can give you a check on e5
and it's almost checkmate you have to go
g3 he starts checking you
it's anybody's game okay if that makes
sense so
your default when you're forked is the
first question you ask yourself can i
move over one piece
and defend the other piece that should
be the way you frame this question to
yourself
oh i see so bringing rook to d1 bingo
okay i'm thinking work to d1 attack the
queen he has to let's say take the pawn
now you take the rook you're up two rows
okay
so you know you shouldn't panic
immediately unless there's a knight fork
that's why it's so good to give a knight
fork because by definition
like knights are the only piece that
move like that so you can't defend
okay so here you took c3 d4 this all
makes perfect sense double the rooks
and the last thing yeah so so does this
plan make sense you're pushing your pass
spawn
yeah and the move g6 is a mistake
because it creates this weakness you're
you're undermining the f7 pawn if he
takes on e6
what do you do taking rook uh there is
something even better
deliver the check first in g6 on public
then take the rook take the pawn
from up perfect clean game
clean [ __ ] clean game
i should reserve the cussing for when
you make one of your stupid moves
okay yeah you gotta keep those in your
back pocket right exactly
otherwise they lose their meaning all
right ready for
the next one okay are we doing another
one just in pool
let's do one more pull one and then
let's do an odds game okay sounds good
thank you jackfrust
i feel like i've heard of this guy
except i don't know where
jack frost no
rye asked your opponent oh oh oh they
said jack frost
ah so he's playing the fried liver yeah
yeah so what was the defense against
this isn't it just normal development
pretty much so it's it's def it's
actually d5 because he's threatening to
take your pawn
right with his knight and deliver a fork
so you got to intercept the bishop
and the bottom line is if he takes with
his pawn you're not supposed to
recapture that pawn with your knight
and i'll show you after the game uh i'll
remind you of the
the key ideas thanks possible and
veronica so you have to move the knight
from c6
and you have to chase away the bishop on
c4 where can the bishop
where can the knight do that from three
five yep
yeah i'll show them the trexler there
there is a cool line where you give up
f7 but
that you know the tracks what it's
called
it's called the traxxler these chess
players take themselves very seriously
i wonder like how many times he
thought about that at night oh i have a
line named after me oh my god queen f3
okay
what is this um this
is this is what we call a bad move yeah
how do you punish said bad move
uh do i just push up pawn to attack the
queen as well
well what if why did you play knight a5
well to attack the bishop but i mean
moved it yeah so i just take it yeah
exactly
i thought there was something bigger i
can do with the queen being out like
that
well i mean i'd say taking a bishop is
it's pretty it's
cool that's cool yeah so e4 like okay
we'll talk about that so now he attacks
your knight
you can just move it yeah do i want to
put it back on its original d6
sure that's a good good square is any in
the center
then you want to make sure well first of
all that knight on g5
it's kind of annoying so i would deal
with that knight first and then i would
complete my development on the king's
side
okay so h6 exactly okay
and thank you guys for the subs i'll
thank you guys when i mute myself
all right h6
yeah now he's a piece down
and so you can take his knight
with either knight actually you also you
actually don't have to and that's a
point that i'm gonna
hammer down you can just continue
developing as normal let him be the one
to take your knights
okay that sounds weird do i want to
develop my c
bishop my light square bishop first to
like g4 or is that just not really no
no because there's a specific reason for
that i'll torture you
over that during after the game but
develop your king's side first okay so
i'm going just
e7 yeah yeah and the sort of general
reason is
you want to take care of your king
safety first uh normally but there is a
tactical reason why you don't want to
attack his queen
also i know you know i appreciate the
raid you were going to buy me out of the
raid think i wasn't going to be
quite as cruel to you boy how wrong you
are amen brother that's what i'm looking
for
yeah so now um he's going to be the one
deciding
do i take his night which night do i
take uh and
when you force your opponent to make
decisions you save time
and they're more likely to make the
wrong decisions okay
so now i'm just gonna castle yeah
exactly
that was a very profound statement you
were supposed to appreciate that
yeah no no no it just uh it probably
sounded a lot cooler when you were
monologuing it
yeah sometimes i'll deliver one of those
to a student and then i'll listen to
myself and i'll be like
like what the hell did i just say what
am i actually saying here
all right so you can see how much time
he's spending he's agonizing over which
night to take
but it's actually not that important for
him from his perspective which night he
takes
okay he doesn't take either
so now i'll give you a hint actually you
do want to take his night with one of
your knights
and you want to do that because you have
a opportunity
to execute a plan that that you executed
in the last game
it involves opening up the king side in
a particular way
yeah so it's taking with the f6 knight
right and that's going to free up the
bingo exactly
and also it's going to free up what
other the queen
well but there's another thing you can
do think pawns
which pawn does it free up where can
that pawn go
are you talking about the f7 pawn i am
if you notice his queen
is actually right by your rook yep yep
yep uh so i'm just pushing to f5
yeah exactly that's a very common plan
in a lot of different positions
particularly when
you're up a piece the bottom line is you
want to open up the position
which i will never stop reminding you of
in order for your extra piece to sort of
make its presence felt so now what no
i'm just going to take freeze up the
file
absolutely and if he when he takes with
the knight
notice that his queen and his knight are
on the same diagonal that should be
uh f5 exactly he's got to play f3 that
weakens his king side
and when he does play f3 which i think
he will
um yep now you got to think about a way
to apply pressure on that knight on e4
you have a maneuver
that brings a piece into the king side
and it applies pressure on the knight
look at all of your pieces which ones
could apply pressure on the knight
there's literally only one piece that
can do that diagonally a little confused
uh so on the king side i'm bringing in a
new piece to the attack on the night
you're bringing the queen in
i'll give you that man where can the
queen go
maneuver the queen to the king's side
so do you want her to go to what eight
first and then slide over
okay that's exactly what we find in one
okay e8 and g6
and the queen serves two purposes that's
what i mean when i say apply pressure
that's a general term for be another
attacker two
gotcha okay
yeah and basically yeah okay that
actually doesn't even stop you from
going queen g6
why does that not blunder the bishop
because i just take it right back with
queen
no because you take his king if you play
queen jesus oh right right right because
it's pinned now
jesus were you really saying that you
would just take back a pawn that
captured your bishop like it's no big
deal
yeah yeah might cut some nuts off so now
um
his night you have three attackers on
his knight
and he has only two defenders the pawn
of the queen what do you want to take
his knight
with um do i take with the knight first
yes
okay you want to keep your bishop the
bishop is a huge attacker then you take
with your bishop and then that
f file is going to be the headquarters
of your attack basically
okay so then now i'm taking bishop
exactly then you want to gain control of
the f-file
depending on what he does
hmm yeah his position is
it has seen better days
okay so now when i say gain control oh
actually you have a really cool move
oh actually yeah you do so you see his
king on g1
uh you want to use the other side of the
board to get to his king i'll give you a
hint it's a queen move
and it's a check yeah it's going to b6
yeah
exactly then his king has to go to h2
but that opens up the f2 square which is
a huge
it's actually checkmate in one two three
four like five or so but it's probably
going to be checkmate in three the way
this the game is going to go
yeah so you see what i'm saying if he
goes king h2
what move are you going to play
i'm just bringing the bishop to d6
there's a much better move there's a
check
and what you should be looking for is
that second rank
so it is a rook move oh
oh jesus here i just bring rook to f2
then yep exactly
and if he takes it it's checkmate he's
probably going to go king to g3
would be my guess
but if he goes king to g1 okay yeah
and now there's checkmate in one move
checkmate and one it's not e3 i get
taken by bishop um it's a ruckmoth
oh it's just bringing the rook back to
f3 no no rook g2
[Music]
if rook f3 he takes that rook although
that's mainly two actually
oh i didn't even notice the bishop
covering h4
okay yeah that's uh well that's just a
coincidence i didn't
personally like know that that would be
you know the result but that's a pretty
cool
cool attack uh and i always like using
the other side of the board that move
queen v6
a lot of people would miss that because
they tunnel vision the king side if that
makes sense
um so let's there's a couple of points i
wanted to make before we
go to our odds games and i finally get a
chance to kick your ass and make you
feel terrible
or maybe i surprise you and beat you in
the odd scheme
keep telling yourself that if you don't
mind let me just grab my coffee that
i've
i'm smelling that delicious smell i'm
gonna keep you and
your eleven thousand viewers waiting
just okay
so in general in order to avoid the
fried liver
you can also develop the bishop first uh
and then the g5 square is covered by
your queen
okay and he can't play knight g5 so
knight f6 knight g5
the traxler is this oop sorry that's not
that that's the
[ __ ] line and that that's actually the
worst move in the position
because you lose the queen because the
queen isn't tripped
so i now slipped the worst move in the
position so bishop c5 is the traxler
um i don't know who traxler was he
wasn't a famous player
uh but the bottom line idea is if white
takes on f7 with a knight
why does it seem like white is winning
like if you just look at this
you can't take the the knight back and
you have to move queen so he gets a rook
yeah he gets a free rogue like what the
hell is black tune but
bishop takes f2 check um is
the idea which is just a crazy looking
move like where is this coming from
but i actually want you to tell me the
follow-up move after king takes up what
what is black going to do here
is he going to deliver another check on
e4 bingo and what does that move do
let's say white just drops his king back
what's the big [ __ ] here
and the reason i'm asking you these
questions i'm really looking quickly
looking up who was the first person to
play the tracks or was it actually
traxler
i'm really interested in this stuff but
also tell me the move
oh is it because you can uh is it
because you bring
queen to f6 and threaten checkmate uh
kind of yeah i think that's actually i
don't actually know there's people in
shadow know this better than i do i
think that's the move
it might also be queen e7 oh queen h4
okay
queen h4 is the move same idea queen out
two yeah that's the move
and there have been articles written
about this people have toiled over this
for
actually for years to determine whether
black is soundly attacking in the
draxler
and then some people came along and
they're like
look [ __ ] like bishop takes f7
avoids this entire thing you don't have
to bother about this
all you do is you take the pawn and you
with the draw the bishop you're up upon
and wha and black has no attacking
opportunities can you tell me why
this no longer works
oh i wasn't doing push to talk i'm sorry
it's because e4 is covered
e4 is covered exactly and i'm just
trying i'll be doing that
throughout just trying to get you to
make these small observations yeah
that's exactly right
anyways so does that make sense yeah my
i downloaded a new version of chessbase
so it's still doing the search i will
make the i know your entire chat is on
the edge of their seats wondering
whether traxler was actually the first
person to play the traxler
um anyways so d5 is the move and now
knight a5
and the reason that to him uh this
so why is knight takes d5 actually bad
do you remember the reason
uh yeah if i i think it's you take
on f7 with knights king takes you bring
queen out to deliver check on f3 yeah
exactly and then this is this is a small
problem called the king out on e6 in the
opening
right and it's not that simple white is
white is better here
um and i remember the first time i got a
chance to play it
it was against i don't know why i
remember this but in 2002 or three
um when i first started playing shots i
was obsessed with ratings so
um my first rating was 803.
um yeah believe it or not i was not i
did not come out of my mother's womb at
gm
i know that's mind-boggling realization
but
i remember like i think the second or
third term when i played it was like a
k-3
california championship and voy boy i
also i think played there
and i played this guy named alex cloud
and alex cloud was rated eleven hundred
and i was so scared of him i was like
telling my dad
i don't wanna play i'm gonna lose to him
and then he went into this line
and all of my fears immediately
dissipated i beat him with this line
amazing story that's beautiful
for the applause are you are you tearing
up yet
yeah that's one of those tearjerker
moments right there did you checkmate
him or did he resign from that position
i think i checkmated him usually kids uh
at that level they they
pl they tend to play until checkmate
and um and by the way i was going to ask
you you've heard of the queen's gambler
right
of course have you managed to watch it
yeah it was good
i enjoyed it nice i'm actually very
happy to hear that but another thing
is the one very nitpicky [ __ ]
grandmaster realization
uh grandmaster criticism is people don't
usually resign
by putting their king down people
usually just resign by stopping the
clock and
extending your hand just so everybody
knows like
it's like
what was that my grandpa taught me the
king thing so i thought that was common
practice
yeah well it used to be like in the
1600s when you were growing up
but anyways okay so uh back to the game
knight a5 queen f3 he blunders the
bishop right
and this is a blockade right you're
blockading the pawn on d5
and h6 chasing it away bishop b7 so
again
when your opponent offers you a trade uh
when you are trading a piece there
should always be
a good reason you can point to for why
you're trading uh and here
yes you're up a piece but you asked me a
question earlier do you always want to
trade when you're up
um if you have a queen trade then
usually that'll be a good idea unless
you're attacking
if you're attacking and you're up a
piece and your opponent offers a queen
trade there's no reason necessarily to
go out of your way
and trade queens right but if your
opponent offers a minor piece trade
knights or bishops
you don't have to freaking go to the
edge of the world just to trade a knight
you can
let him be the one here you trade
because you open the f
pawn um so f d takes e4 f5 opening up
the file
and this was the critical moment right
queenie 8.26 does this make sense now
yeah so queenie a queen 26 applying
pressure on the knight
by the way if he plays knight takes d6
what piece do you take i do i take back
with the bishop
uh so you mean you take the knight yeah
if you were to take the knight you would
stick with the bishop correct and then
what move would you play to open up this
bishop
i just pushed the pawn beautiful e4
however
you have another possibility here this
simplifies the position and wins even
more material try to calculate this out
and in the meantime i have some news for
you holy [ __ ]
trexler and his first name
was carol traxler uh was the first
person
to play the traxler and he played it in
1890
and then he played it again in 1896 and
then the next person to play it was in
1931 so he literally had this all to
himself
for 50 years whoa he won both of the
games that he played it in
damn this guy was this guy was pretty
cool i have to say
his first name was carol k-a-r-e-l
czechoslovakia
born in 1866 died in 1936 aged 84.
he lived happily ever after after
playing the tracks then
man can you understand charlie this guy
was our age he was 24
when he first developed this line that
we're talking about today i mean
these guys were or giga chads as i guess
we say now
is that how how we talk now you need to
you need to have a line named after you
daniel
you know it's funny because there's a
couple of lines that i've i play more
often than other gm's
that i think aren't considered are
considered to be a little suspicious
maybe one day
i'll have the honor of having that i'll
try and brainstorm some goofy
[ __ ] for you to refine it could be a
team effort oh
i'd love that but back to this position
sorry to distract you with that
meaningless information
um what move am i talking about here the
knight is not the only piece you can
take
yeah so i'm just taking the queen in
trading right
but let's calculate bishop takes queen
knight takes queen
what do you do there uh then i'm taking
rook
with the bishop exactly and if he takes
the bishop
bishop takes queen knight takes queen
bishop takes rook
that knight on e8 takes c7 attacking
your rook
how do you save both your rook and your
bishop at the same time
i just bring the rook over to e8
uh oh no he still takes that yeah
you're correct to bring the rook over
somewhere but your default question
should be can i attack the knight with
the rook
yeah okay um so i just bring it over to
c8 then
exactly and okay if we play the line on
the board what i was talking about
knight attacks royal king attacks bishop
as i told you first question can i move
one piece
and either defend the other piece well
obviously bishop cannot defend rook rook
and not defend bishop
so the next best thing to attack one of
the attackers okay
okay there's more to this but just
wanted to get you to calculate a little
bit
and basically at the end you take with
the bishop and this is the key move
queen b6 this makes sense now right
yeah last thing um if he
well if he takes then of course you take
with the queen and it's checkmate
if he plays king back to g1 there's a
lot going on here can you actually check
maybe from this position
let this be our segway into the odds
games
moving rook to g2 does not check mate um
[Music]
yeah you have to make a key observation
about white's king
and where it's sort of placed
i can draw a particular arrow and that
might help you out
yeah but it still wouldn't be checkmate
right like if i move that rook oh
i'm not made in one by the way like i'm
not expecting you to deliver mate on the
next move
okay cool yeah because that just can't
happen right but i move well i would i
would expect traxxar to do that but hey
you're not at that level of coolness so
you'll need a couple extra moves
we'll get there so do i start by just
going g2 with the rook
uh so the funny thing is if you go to g2
that's a double check
which is good the bad thing and that's a
fine move uh it
it but it delays the mating process
because that king slides over to h1
if you move the rook anywhere but that
square this bishop is going to
protect that square uh i'm just moving
it back to like f4
or not f4 but like all the way back to
like f6 then just get that boy
he gets h2 so you have to move the rook
so that the rook still controls the h2
square
[Music]
oh because i'm delivering the check
right now right right right remember the
key concept discover check
is the most powerful tactical tool in
chefs
um and by the way even if it wasn't made
you'd be winning his queen
right right but as it stands it's just
mate because he can throw a bunch of
pieces at you you take them all
so remember discover checks
this makes sense now right the bishop on
e7 defending yeah
fantastic okay um so are you fine with
an odds game or two i feel like that's a
good way to sort of
recap some basic principles and also get
you to feel bad about yourself which
yeah ultimately you know my goal
so let's do let's do a 15 minute game to
start down a queen
um unless you want to do 10 minutes but
i think 15 minutes is good just for now
because
yeah you know it gives me a chance to
run off at the mouth
we'll do 15 plus two okay
rated definitely unrated all right
challenge due if you did do rated and i
won would you go back down to like a
thousand elo
well the thing is i usually play blitz
and 15 minutes is considered
rapid i think and i don't really play
much uh formal rapid so
but you know uh the hit on my ego would
be
you know insurmountable yeah you would
never recover
no